one thing that came up for me you know
I've been I've been I have found
mcquarters contention that this is a
religious movement and this is not
really metaphor even though this is akin
to religion that this is like religion a
very compelling argument for years now
and I think it was a 20-18 article that
he wrote that really put it into sharp
relief for me and I was wondering though
whether and you know maybe this is
something you can ask him when you're on
with him next whether he would call the
Cultural Revolution and Maoist doctrine
a religion as well what do you what do
you think you have any opinions on that
yeah my guess would be that he will
think that there is an over a lot of
overlap yeah and I guess the question I
would have is given your in my
perspective about what religion is and
how it came about that it is an
evolutionary phenomenon that this may
actually be an empirical question right
there may actually be circuitry that is
called into play when one goes into a
religious modality and so it may you
know it may be a matter of a brain scan
could reveal whether somebody is in that
mindset or not yeah I mean I I guess I
tend to think of religious belief and
you know the tenants that have stood the
test of time
emerging slowly and becoming dominant
over time and so the thing that has
seemed so dangerous about this current
movement that has been you know ongoing
for decades actually but is it fever
pitch right now
and similarly about how ism was that it
was this top-down authoritarian
extraordinarily quick thing and actually
if I if I could just read a very brief
paragraph this is this is one of the
books on the cultural revolution that
I've been reading I don't know how to
pronounce the guy's name he's excellent
Frank D Coulter Dutch the third in a in
a trilogy the Cultural Revolution of
people's history 1962 to 1976 he has on
page 168 a quotation from an office
worker who's remembering 1968 sort of
early Cultural Revolution every morning
he says we would stand in front of this
with our little red books and read
a few passages then waving the little
red book we would say three times great
leader teacher helmsman Chairman Mao may
you live ten thousand years and good
health forever - vice-chairman lianbao
it struck me as absurd almost like a
religion
most of us felt that way as I was to
discover after the Cultural Revolution
at the time however no one in their
right mind would dare say so openly let
alone discuss it that seems so much like
what we're seeing now this the culture
of fear that is spreading and as I have
said to you in the last couple of days
and I actually just tweeted just before
we went on I think there is a close
analogy to be made between Mao's little
red book and Robin D'Angelo's white
fragility these these books are being
passed around they're being waved as
badges of True Believer ship and also as
ways to basically bludgeon those who
don't fall into line
[Music]